[Música]
en directo a nos vamos a Ecuador porque
se registra una nueva tragedia
carcelaria Y de nuevo en un penal de
Guayaquil seis Ríos fueron hallados
ahorcados en un hecho que vuelve
evidenciar la crisis carcelaria por la
que pasa este país conectamos con
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
Gustavo la lucha por el control de las
cárceles y las pugnas del crimen
organizado por El dominio de las rutas
de narcotráfico en las calles parecen
agudizar la crisis de inseguridad que
vive la nación andina
Así es Buenas noches Juan tú como tú lo
has dicho el día de hoy una nueva crisis
carcelaria un suceso que fue anunciado
por el ejecutivo nacional cuando seis
presos fueron encontrados colgando el
día de hoy en la cárcel del litoral que
obedece a la ciudad de Guayaquil se
informó el día de hoy luego que los
guías penitenciarios haciendo una
revisión de los pabellones en el
pabellón número cinco encontrarán a
estas seis personas no se ha dicho mayor
información y es lo que reclaman los
familiares de los privados de libertad
si estas personas inclusive pertenecían
a bandas del crimen organizado si tenía
algún tipo de señales de violencia lo
que sí se ha dicho es que fueron
encontradas en el pabellón número cinco
en la cárcel de Guayaquil y Juan está
dividida en 12 pabellones pero cada una
tiene presencia de los distintos grupos
organizados y pretenden controlar los
pabellones que habitan en este caso
fueron encontrados en el pabellón número
cinco que en el cual lideran y pre
imponer su ley la organización del
crimen organizado de los Águilas ha
dicho así El Ejecutivo nacional esta
organización de delincuencial se
caracterizaba por extorsionar a las
personas que aquí residían Él el
presidente de la república ha dicho que
todo lo que sucede en las cárceles
forman parte de las acciones de los
grupos delincuencia organizada por
hacerse con el control de las cárceles
Juan Gustavo de otra parte del
presidente Guillermo lasso ha emitido
nuevas medidas para intentar controlar
la crisis de seguridad en Ecuador luego
de esa masacre ocurrió ayer en Puerto
pesquero en el puerto pesquero artesanal
de la provincia de esmeraldas frontera
con Colombia Cuál es la estrategia del
mandatario
bueno la estrategia del mandatario ha
sido criticado fuertemente en materia de
seguridad y se realiza el día de hoy una
reunión de seguridad específicamente en
las ciudades esmeraldas y lo que ha
dicho es que ha dispuesto a sacar a las
calles a las fuerzas armadas Para apoyar
a la Policía Nacional ha dicho también
que responsabilizará a los líderes de
los distintos grupos delincuenciales que
ya se encuentran apresados para que
asuman responsabilidad por este tipo de
suceso también ha dicho que
defenderá judicialmente a los efectivos
policiales que hagan así actúen en
materia de proteger el orden en las
cárceles ha dicho también que se
mantiene en este momento un aproximado
de dos mil efectivos policiales junto a
las fuerzas armadas que han rodeado la
provincia de esmeraldas una de las
ciudades más violentas de el país esto
sucede también luego de que hace una
semana ocurrió otra reyerta en la cárcel
de la roca una de la cárcel de mayor
peligrosidad en este país donde habita
en este momento 23 rreos y lo cual se
registraron tres personas muertas ha
dicho también que forman parte de las
acciones por dominar las calles y las
rutas del narcotráfico Hace algunos
minutos también el presidente de la
república desde la corte constitucional
denunciaba lo que las zonas pretensiones
de los grupos organizados para dividir
las instituciones y hacerse con el
control del estado